it is the 1st of june 2022 so it's time
for another monthly update video in
which i'll talk about what went on in
may that you might have missed
what is coming up in june that you
probably want to get in on and a few
other things as well i always like to
begin by highlighting three big things
so big thing number one is that i am
offering
a course on light hall on aristotle and
his
conception of the virtues i'll tell you
more about that in the
june section but i want to put that on
your radar it'll start at near the end
of june um the second big thing is that
i started a new video series on fake
quotes from famous philosophers i kicked
it off with one on aristotle with some
of the most egregious
fake quotes that you see floating around
and i'll be doing more of those and big
thing number three is that i'm going to
be
resuming not not doing a completely a
new original kind of video but resuming
a kind of video that i did in the past
the ideas that matter series
and
you know those were sit down interviews
i'm going to be doing those now using
zoom so that i can talk with people all
over the world and i think it's kind of
a cool thing to start up doing again
these these interviews talking about
some really interesting things with some
really interesting people so those are
the three big things
lots of other things to put on your
horizon
may started out with me in kind of a bad
way i had contracted covid towards the
end of april i was in isolation up here
on the second floor i couldn't even work
here at this desk in part because i
didn't have the energy and you know with
my wife down below i'd have to be masked
up and so i i wasn't shooting in front
of the chalkboard or anything like that
at the start of may and i was you know
having a rough time fortunately it was a
mild case of covid but mild covet is
still rougher than a lot of other things
that i've dealt with and you know i've
gotten better but i'm still suffering
from
some unpredictable fatigue what they
call nowadays long coved
and um i even did a video about that
that i'll i'll tell you about in just a
minute
um so you know i did spend some time
this month uh creating videos a lot of
times stuff that i could adapt without
having to get up in front of the
chalkboard again i did get in the front
of the chalkboard towards the end of the
month
um did some podcasting work you know
taking my other lecture videos and
converting them into sadler's lectures
podcast did a good bit of writing as
well
and a lot of reading because i was laid
up so a lot of sci-fi and fantasy
reading um and my classes came to an end
you know my carthage classes and i'm not
going to be teaching at carthage anymore
going forward from this point
my carthage class is finished up around
the middle of the month my my ad class
classes
finished officially at the
the beginning of may but we had a few
stragglers within completes that are now
resolved so
that's good you know spring semester
is behind me
um i did you know quite a few online
events i still did an ama and asked me
anything
session i did worlds of speculative
fiction on ola stapleton
heavy metal class me and scott did some
cool album reviews eight of them
actually have recent albums by classic
metal bands
um you know i held my my hegel sessions
i did the milwaukee stoic online session
as well
and i continued on with the basics of
stoicism live streaming events
we talked about in one session the
virtue of justice in another session the
virtue of courage
i also did something new which was the
light hall session i was giving it a try
this new platform that i am actually
quite happy with and i'm going to be
doing more stuff so i did something on
five stoic practices in epictetuses and
creating i'm going to be following that
up this month with another session on
five additional practices in epictetuses
and caribbean
and i did also a presentation while i
still had kovid and it really wore me
out but it was a good presentation to do
on um
anselm on divine simplicity in the
trinity for the dionysius circle uh that
was an online presentation
and you know i i actually had to put off
quite a few of my my clients for the
first week of may but then i resumed
doing tutorials and philosophical
counseling and academic coaching and you
know talking about different projects
and stuff like that
so videos um i
released some of the
half hour hegel videos that i'd done the
previous month and i did get two new
ones shot that are available already for
patreon supporters of the project
they'll be coming out later this month
and i did some core concept videos i
didn't shoot them in front of the
chalkboard instead i took the footage
that i'd used
for my online business ethics classes
and uh which have been uploaded
elsewhere you can't find them in my main
channel well now you can because i
turned them into core concept videos on
um uh norman bowie's
business ethics and on milton friedman's
famous you know the responsibility of a
business is to increase its profits
uh editorial that he wrote a while back
i also remastered a number of the
epictetus and caridian commentary videos
didn't quite finish up with those but i
got a lot of those
done so that that's good um
event videos and the class videos
they're all linked to below if you click
the you know show more
all these things you can find in the
video description
i also did a caption contest i hadn't
done one of those for a while so i did
uh one with sassy i'm still missing in
our old 19 year old cat
died back in april and uh you know still
missing her quite a bit
um i did that fake quotes video on
aristotle you know i took the i went to
the sites where you find all these fake
quotes being you know passed around and
you know
took their their their images and then i
did a video talking about why these are
fake quotes and you know when we know
where they came from where they actually
came from and why
none of them are things that aristotle
would actually have said anybody who
actually knows aristotle would know that
but most people don't right and so this
is kind of a
my little contribution to cleaning up
the uh philosophy
internet sphere um we also
did a video on a twitter conversation
where a journalist kind of stepped in it
telling academics how they ought to
right and i did a video that i released
just yesterday
uh reflections on life lessons talking
about what it was like for me to have
covid and how i'm still suffering some
long-term effects from it and
some of the impact that's had on my work
life
you know cutting into it considerably
and
some of the ways i've been rethinking
how i'm going to
have a sustainable work life practice in
my 50s which is where i am
and uh beyond
um the other thing to talk about is
podcast i did a lot of podcast episodes
because those didn't require me to you
know
do much of anything other than sit at a
desk and so
uh quite a few uh aristotle podcast
episodes we finished up with on you know
his conceptions of justice uh
prudentius's psychomachia a text that i
taught earlier this semester
some augustine city of god book 19
richard dawkins the selfish gene a text
i'm teaching this summer again and
finally
epictetus
uh podcast episode so
quite a quite a few of those and uh so
that's what we got done during
may obviously covid put a big
crimp into my productivity
one that's probably going to continue
for for at least months to come so that
is may
we got a lot of stuff coming up in the
month of june i'm going to be going to a
conference here one that i look forward
to every year at marquette university a
little bit later on in the month
aristotle and the aristotelian tradition
that's always a fun conference and it's
going to be in person this year so i'm
going to go to it
my events begin on the fourth that is a
saturday at noon i've got my ama that's
ask me anything session live streaming
and it literally you can ask me anything
um you know you probably want to get
your questions in at the start because i
get too many to possibly answer in the
hour and a half that i a lot to it
later on that afternoon at two o'clock
central time all these times are central
time i will have my philosophy chat for
patreon supporters uh kind of a perk
that i have with them you know if they
want to have a more intimate
conversation with me that's something
that you can do
on the fifth so the sunday we'll have
another basics of stoicism session and
we're going to be finishing our
discussion of the four cardinal virtues
so we're going to look at temperance
we've already talked about wisdom
justice and courage now we get to
temperance which includes a lot of stuff
for the stoics that will be a lot of fun
and you know if you if you get there you
can ask questions uh in the chat if you
miss it there'll be a video
on the 8th at 5 00 p.m i'll have my
public hegel q a and discussion session
uh open to anybody
supported by the half-hour hegel project
patreon but you don't have to be a
member to to join in
on the 12th i'm going to have a free
class on light hall at noon central time
and that will be the continuation of
five more stoic practices from
epictetuses and caribbean as it turns
out there's there's a lot of stoic
practices in there and so i'm going to
be giving you some of the best high
impact ones that you can apply to
your own life and we'll have lots of
time for q a in between each of the
practices talk about how you'd apply it
and you know a lot a lot of good stuff
there
on the um
18th we will have our classic metal
class
oh i almost forgot um we do have on the
11th at noon the worlds of speculative
fiction
and that is going to be looking at
veronica roth's carve the mark universe
there's two novels and a couple short
stories
very recent stuff and i've actually met
veronica roth and this is going to be a
a lot of fun so video premiere at 12 and
then zoom conversation at 1 30 following
up on that
coming back on the next saturday the
18th at noon scott taruli and i will be
having classic metal class session
number 20.
we're going to be discussing we're
reprising the question of who's an
original member of a band because rudy
sarzo
one of the you know people who's very
central in the band quiet riot
has called himself and made some good
arguments for while he's not a
completely original member of the band
he's an original member of the metal
health quiet riot era so we're going to
do some metaphysical discussion about
what constitutes originality and and
some aesthetic stuff and that'll be a
lot of fun you can join us for that
conversation
on the 19th
at noon i will be reprising the
self-directed study
videos and doing a video premiere i'm
not quite sure yet who i'm going to do
there's a lot of thinkers to get to to
give some advice about how you could go
about studying them so i'll i'll pick
that fairly soon and get that posted
on the 25th we will be doing
at noon political theory and practice
discussion
and then on the 28th
i will be starting a new
course that runs for eight weeks with
lighthaul and this is a paid course it
costs eighty dollars but you get eight
sessions out of it i'll be doing the
sessions uh weekly and there's plenty
more information if you just click below
you know i don't have to go into all the
particulars here but what is the topic
aristotle on the moral virtues so we're
going to be talking about all the
different moral virtues that aristotle
goes into in the nick of mccain and
eudaimian ethics we'll also be talking
about the importance of prudence in
guiding a person towards moral virtue so
if you if you really want a you know
kind of intensive study of how aristotle
understood moral virtue one of the most
important people in virtue ethics
studying with somebody who's been you
know reading
teaching this stuff for
close to three decades you might want to
sign up for that class
what else do we have going on i'll be
doing a lot of um video production
so you know um half hour hegel i want to
start getting getting myself back up to
four videos a month i do want to get
this
this book done by the end of the year
right and i'm going to be doing some
book review videos i've actually got one
ready to roll
and i'll be doing a lot more of them
this month core concept videos i'm going
to continue on with the business ethics
stuff with a great set on robert audi's
classic article about virtue ethics and
business also going to be doing some
stuff on flip a foot on the trolley
problem because i'm teaching that
this
summer for my my classes that i'll tell
you about in just a minute um
i'll also be doing some personal videos
um i've got a lot of footage of
sassy the cat and uh for those who are
willing to sit through you know about an
hour's worth of stuff i'm going to do a
tribute video like i did with our dogs
when they died and also about sassy's
sister teensy i'll be doing some other
personal videos as well
i don't know exactly what i'll be
talking about but probably some sadler's
stories and probably some some other
stuff
um i might do some more of those
sadler's asides and digressions uh
videos people seem to like that i'm
going to be remastering the remainder of
the epictetus videos and of course
there'll be all these events and
interview videos coming up as well
and i'm going to shoot some more videos
specifically for my introduction to
philosophy class about you know some
some really basic key things having to
do with philosophy and so that's a good
segue into talking about what am i doing
this summer
well i'm teaching one academic class
that starts in late june and it's
introduction to philosophy for my
milwaukee institute of art and design
students and it's a challenge to to
teach in such a compressed format
but i'm you know
i've got some good ideas about what i'm
going to do maybe i'll do some writing
about you know how i'm structuring it i
will tell you this the students are
learning about how to
find philosophy on the internet and how
to do philosophy through the internet so
they're not just writing papers they're
writing blog posts creating podcast
episodes
making and analyzing memes very very
cool class
i'm also offering that light hall class
as i mentioned which is for anybody who
wants to take it you know uh eight weeks
doing a fairly intensive study of
aristotle on moral virtue going into a
deep dive like we'll have an entire
session just on aristotle on anger one
entire session is devoted to how we deal
with money in generosity and
magnificence we'll be doing an entire
session just on justice so it's it's
going to be a really great class and you
probably want to check it out just to
see if it would be for you
um
i'll be you know doing some other online
class release stuff more things that
aren't um
live but rather you know you can study
at your own pace in my teachable reason
i owe academy i'm working on some class
stuff for listenable which are audio
classes and i might i might launch some
email classes as well for those who like
to do things at their own pace
and then what else you know i'm working
with clients of course
tutorials and philosophical counseling
and coaching and stuff like that i am
doing a few uh podcast things going on
other people's podcasts so you can
see those in my social media when they
come out because it's on their schedule
obviously
and then finally the podcast what am i
going to be doing in the sadler's
lectures podcast
i got some stuff that i did a while back
on the
cynics coming from authors like lucian
and xenophon and diogenes laertes so i'm
working through those and you'll see
those released
probably later on this week
and
finishing up with the epictetus
stuff i still have more that i could do
but we'll leave him alone for a while
and then i've got some podcast episodes
on plato's republic that i really need
to do i think
and
we've got some uh stuff on augustine's
confessions from the videos that i shot
for my medieval philosophy class
converting those into podcast episodes
and that'll probably take me to the end
of the month so a lot of stuff lined up
hope it's a great month for all of you
it's a beautiful time here in the
mke the milwaukee area right so maybe
i'll see some of you in person if not i
hope to see you at these various online
events and classes and other venues
where we can meet up and have a great
month
you